I actually hate it you know they are
just like me and I am uneducated on
their religion expose me guys
I'll have enough now let's move on to
the next thing what he said he said some
some words now sometimes when we hear
something in another language we can't
appreciate it expect my guys are humble
enough I want to say something he says
and hamdulillah al hamdulillah what does
that mean why is he saying something in
another language in Arabic now I want to
connect this again back to the one I'm
sure many Christians who love Jesus
people who are even maybe Christian but
they heard Jesus they have they have a
connection to him do you know that Jesus
he called on the creator if you ever
watched the The Passion of Christ
and keep her long doc you hold our Costa
yeah Allah in Arabic it just Allah this
is the creator we're talking about and
he is saying al hamdulillah al
hamdulillah everything God gave me so
again he's keeping it humble if anything
we could take away from this video is is
is that quality of keeping it humble we
got too much we're all susceptible to an
ego the ego can take over and you become
very arrogant who likes to be around
arrogant people keeping this humble
again he's saying a hum delight just
like saying thank you God everything God
gave me but very simple now you can pre
can you appreciate that let's go on to
the next thing Allah videos and the last
but not the least Allah but here I'm
saying Allah Allah Allah what what does
it mean is it some war cry jihad they're
coming to get us
how ridiculous is that sound but that's
what some people think do you know that
over 60,000 books in a span of a hundred
years had been written against Islam
according to The Times Magazine article
published in 1979 April 16th I believe
it was and at the Islamic phobia
industries are 250 million dollar annual
business so you know probably the
information you got the book you read
false propaganda fear-mongering and the
hate mongers they're making money
bashing throwing dirt on Islam so Allah
who X but is not a war cry
it's simply Allah God is greater greater
than that money that dollar that job
that woman everything that you can
imagine God Almighty the Creator Allah
is greater than this and again going
back to keeping it humble always
thanking the one who gave you the
abilities to win that championship to
get up in the morning
to eat the wonderful food to breathe
this air you don't got to go to Walmart
to get it it's free so you say God
Almighty's great Lexi hallelujah
hallelujah
you've heard that Allahu Allah ugh but
God Almighty is the greatest Allah so
that's what could be be say now helped
you to familiarize yourself with some of
the things that he does what Muslims do
in general because Kabir is a Muslim one
who has consciously submitted to the
crater that heavens in the earth and
some of those stereotypes that one might
have in the back of his head he's heard
this term Allah but now if you were to
equate because Islam is a beautiful way
of life calling you have peace with the
Creator peace within yourself so you can
have that peace that money can buy and
you have peaceful humanity if you were
to take all the Isis and the Boko Haram
and al-qaeda which which didn't even
exist a decade ago it's because all of
these wars is that hate war hate
violence terrorism cycle that we got to
stop innocent blood here there
everywhere is human life we got to
condemn one condemned all and when you
have any large group of people you're
going to have radicals you're going to
have extremists but we also have to see
what's the root of all this and Islam is
not the root my friends know Islam
brings that peace and happiness into
one's life when someone has peace and
happiness
he's not trying to blow nobody up
specially himself for innocent people
but you have these things going on but
this is a geopolitical thing and if you
were to add up all of these groups this
is just a sign I'm going off on a
tangent Isis Boko Haram and all these
groups I'm sure you've heard and people
out there associated some people going
to watch this video they're going to
think you know again those those because
of the effect of the Islamophobia
machine so take all these radical groups
compare that to the over 1.7 billion
Muslims all over the globe it would only
equate to you have this small fringe
element to the 1.7 billion last time I
checked it'll be like zero point zero
zero six percent it's like taking the
cake
Lord's Resistance Army or some of these
de secular atheist grooves PKK and all
the time ol Tigers all of these beasties
these terrorist groups and now you try
to pump them up put them up as if
they're exemplary representatives of
Christianity of secularism of atheism
whatever is that wouldn't be fair that
wouldn't be right
you can't take a radical fringe element
and try to pump them up as if they
represent Islam they don't they don't
represent Habib they don't represent me
they don't represent over 1.7 billion
Muslims who again are trying to keep it
humble keep it simple live a peaceful
life like everyone else people who have
connected with Muslims
John dutcher well straight out tell you
what he thought of Muslims I actually
hated the women with her headdress on
you know I just was sneer at him
dutcher was surrounded by the people he
loads but Muslims moving in moved him it
took this - um yeah - to wake me you
know wake me up yeah a change of heart
for the man who didn't realize he had
such a big heart you know what struck me
the most honestly was when I took a
minute to actually talk to some of the
Muslim people to find out you know they
are just like me and I am uneducated on
their religion you know I could easily
make as many mistakes judgment calls as
any other person out there but when I
took a second to sit down and listen to
them and actually enter their mosque in
going and watch some of their prayers it
was a beautiful thing and they answered
some of my questions that I had and I
just feel that maybe that that's
something that they should do too for
the people a lot a lot of us are
uneducated you know educate us on your
religion let us know that not everybody
is a bad bad person said I am very
to see you here thank you for being here
this is America and I just want to say
as a Christian to all my Muslim brothers
and sisters that we are glad to have you
we are you are our neighbors we've been
with you over resist any attempts to
hurt you and please reach out to us we
will reach out to you thank you very
much I've made the human connection
they've seen past all the fear-mongering
and all the hype and now that's it we're
going to curtail it one more I got a
bonus free